bonjour aujourd'hui 30 octobre nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine voici les principaux titres le
député yvelinois jean frédéric poisson
était en syrie cette semaine en
déplacement qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre le président du parti chrétien
démocrate est en plateau nous parlons
avec lui aussi de sa candidature à la
primaire à droite pour 2017 et des
élections régionales les derniers
préparatifs avant halloween les enfants
attendent l'évènement comment bien
choisir son costume nous sommes allés
prendre conseil dans des anciennes mieux
spécialisés et puis comme chaque fin de
semaine l'essentiel de l'actualité
depuis lundi dans les yvelines
déplacement de 18 ministres aux mureaux
dix ans après les émeutes en banlieue ou
encore départ du centre de recherche de
l'inria de rocquencourt je reçois donc
jean frédéric poisson bonsoir bienvenue
à député des yvelines de la 10e
circonscription celle de rambouillet
président du parti chrétien démocrate
candidat également la primaire à droite
pour 2017 vous revenez de syrie c'est la
deuxième fois que vous vous rendez là
bas pour un échange avec le président
bachar al assad
françois hollande lui a coupé toute
relation diplomatique avec damas depuis
le début de la guerre civile si réel
qu'est ce qui vous rend légitime dans ce
déplacement et qu'est ce qui vous rend
légitime surtout pour aller sur place
est finalement condamné l'attitude du
président français ce qui me rend
légitime c'est que je suis un
représentant du peuple français et que à
partir du moment où les intérêts de la
france sont en danger à cause de la
crise en syrie
à cause des flux ininterrompu de
migrants qui viennent de cette région et
que nous ne sommes pas capables
d'accueillir dans des conditions
stabiliser et digne dans notre pays à
partir du moment où les intérêts
l'influencent la présence de la france
dans cette région du monde
s'étiole se délite d'une manière qu'il
sera très très difficile de récupérer
je considère de mon devoir d'aller sur
place d'abord comprendre ce qui est en
cours
discuter avec les acteurs puisque comme
vous le disiez très justement nous
n'avons plus depuis trois ans et demi de
relations diplomatiques avec la syrie
c'est en fait nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon et alain juppé qui ont cessé les
relations avec cet état
et donc puisque les intérêts de la
france sont en jeu puisque le
gouvernement semble ne pas s'en occuper
il me paraît de mon devoir comme
représentant des intérêts de la
française il ya inverse de la position
du gouvernement mais bien en tant que
1ère commande de ne pas ouvertement le
gouvernement français a parfaitement le
droit de penser ce qu'il veut
d'ailleurs y ferez mieux de penser un
peu moins de faire un peu plus c'est ma
liberté de parlementaires et de
représentants du peuple que d'aller voir
sur place et de dire si je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la politique du
gouvernement et c'est le cas vous dites
que ce déplacement n'était pas fait pour
soutenir bachar el assad malgré tout
vous avez bien le sentiment vous vous
rendez bien compte en tout cas que ça
lui offre une tribune
mais le président assad n'a pas besoin
de la visite de parlementaires étrangers
pour avoir une tribune où il est assez
grand pour sa part de votre côté vous
avez mal sentiments vous n'avez pas le
sentiment d'être instrumentalisés non
pas du tout comment dire d'ailleurs le
président assad l'a reconnu lui-même
lors de notre conversation il nous a dit
textuellement vous n'êtes pas là pour me
soutenir politiquement ou parce que vous
êtes d'accord avec moi vous êtes là pour
comprendre ce qui se passe c'est
exactement le cas et je ne regrette pas
d'avoir effectué ce déplacement par car
je sais de source maintenant
parfaitement convaincue et direct cu non
seulement une autre politique est
nécessaire mais qu'elle est possible et
quand je vois que la france s'obstine à
être dans le sillage des saoudiens des
qatari des turcs qui mène un double
triple quadruple jeu dans cette histoire
quand je lis et c'est une information
publique que les seuls représentants
légitimes du peuple syrien reconnu par
la france et laurent fabius sont des
gens qui disent s'il faut choisir entre
des chais assad moi je choisis d'aller
chez bien je suis désolé le français que
je suis député que je suis si le choisir
entre d'ail hachée assad et c'est un
choix pardon un peu difficile malgré
tout je choisis assad est pas d'âge et
vous avez l'impression qu'assad s'engage
vers une voie démocratique justement
écouter ce qu'on fera pas revenir sur
tout l'historique et tous les précédents
mais bon il ya eu les mêmes des
attentats dont il ya plein de choses
l'association série les attentes a
soutenu le régime syrien en bleu régime
syrien et n'est pas un régime
démocratique c'est peu de le dire
c'est un régime dictatorial c'est clair
il a fait beaucoup de torts et beaucoup
de mal dans un pays qui est chère à mon
coeur que le liban et j'étais à beyrouth
a dîné avec des libanais franco libanais
encore lundi soir donc je vois très
clair sur cette question je ne suis pas
dans une perspective morale sur sur le
sujet vous comprenez quand il a fallu
s'allier à staline pour battre hitler
churchill s'est posé moins de questions
et d'ailleurs les occidentaux aussi de
temps en temps c'est malheureux c'est
déplorable
ça ne règle pas tout de temps en temps
il faut choisir ses alliances et moi je
dis que entre s'allier avec des turcs
des saoudiens et des qatari qui
soutiennent en réalité al qaïda et les
frères musulmans d'un côté et d'un autre
côté assad qui est ce qu'il est sans
doute un régime très dictatorial
tortionnaires même par certains degrés
mais qui combat l'état islamique et le
fondamentalisme musulman
encore une fois mon choix est clair il
est fait et c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire comprendre à mes collègues et aux
français depuis votre retour de cyril
vous avez été sollicité par le
gouvernement vous avez échangé avec
françois hollande nous n'ont sûrement
pas est ce que vous êtes là pour
convaincre à metz ne vous inquiétez pas
il va aussi falloir échanges et alex
merci à graissessac bagdad et merci de
me donner aujourd'hui un moyen
supplémentaire de pouvoir le faire et
j'ai fait une tournée assez complète des
médias écrits et audiovisuels depuis mon
retour et même sur place déjà le message
est parfaitement parvenus à l'elysée je
pense que le gouvernement français
souffre du syndrome du chat en haut de
l'arbre c'est à dire qu'il ya plus guère
qu'une échelle de pompiers pour leur
descendre il est monté tellement haut
que maintenant il sait plus comment s'en
sortir mais vous comprenez bien que
cette diplomatie qui est qui est
étonnamment aveuglé par sa propre
idéologie ne sert pas les intérêts
français
tant que tout le monde est en train de
changer d'avis madame merkel dit il faut
dialoguer avec bachar al assad
mariano rajoy le premier ministre
espagnol dit la même chose les
autrichiens le disent les hongrois le
disent les italiens le murmure l'egypte
est en train de changer de camp et de
changer d'avis enfin toute la situation
évolue une vitesse extrêmement rapide il
ya que la france qui reste obstinément
aveugle et dans son chemin parce que
elle estime qu'elle a raison contre tout
le monde et que il ne faudrait pas
changé
je pense que c'est une erreur très grave
et mon rôle de parlementaire libre c'est
de dénoncer cette erreur est de proposer
des alternatives
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
on va mettre de côté cette question de
politique internationale puisque vous
êtes aussi en plateau pour évoquer la
politique en france et à commencer par
les régionales en ile-de-france pour une
impasse 16 octobre cet article tout de
même du figaro avec cet intitulé
régional le coup de gueule des chrétiens
démocrates contre les républicains que
se passe-t-il avec vos alliés ah bah
écoutez c'est simple un peu partout en
france
nous on nous explique que il faut faire
passer un certain nombre de
représentants des formations modem et
parfois udi qui sont considérés comme
des alliés plus sûrs et plus efficaces
que nous le serions nous mêmes sur la
liste des républicains je pense que
c'est une erreur stratégique
je pense que la bonne manière de
procéder utt de laisser chacun faire ses
propres listes au premier tour de
l'élection et bénéficier à la fois des
mécaniques de report et puis puisque les
gens ont envie de se compter bien qu'ils
se comptent
après tout on a droit aussi d'aller à
une élection personne ne peut en être
empêché et ensuite de nouer des
alliances qui permet des dynamiques de
reports de voix les républicains n'ont
pas fait ce choix
donc le problème c'est les places
éligibles en diable elle a poussé mais
les places en position éligible bien je
dis c'est à dire démocrate nous sommes
un parti politique
installé dans la scène publique avec des
élus partout en france
nous avons participé à la gestion des
régions va participer dans l'opposition
régionale là où nous sommes dans le
mandat précédent
il démarre pas parfaitement normal que
nous ayons maintenant aussi la
reconnaissance de ce travail
malheureusement ce coup de gueule a
servi justement est-ce qu'on a utilisées
dans les premières listes royal régions
notamment en ile-de-france moyennement
même si en ile de france tout se meut
parvenu à un accord avec valérie
pécresse dont je souhaite la victoire
d'abord parce que je pense qu'elle sera
une présidente de région efficace avec
le niveau de vision qui convient pour un
territoire de cette importance je lui
fait confiance aussi pour donner toute
son importance à la partie rurale de
l'île de france puisque l'on savait que
nous autres élus ruraux nous avons
parfois du mal à nous faire entendre
circonscription de rambouillet dreux la
cl en particulier à rambouillet et puis
troisièmement je pense qu'il est
absolument indispensable de battre la
gauche dont le bilan est absolument
catastrophique monsieur bartolone ne
s'intéresse pas à la région et
s'intéresse à elle
c'est son droit mais il n'est pas là
pour ça le bilan de monsieur huchon est
une catastrophe et ses alliés c'est
pareil le front national n'a pas de
solution donc il faut que valérie
pécresse gamme nous avons trouvé un
accord hier qui nous donne une place
raisonnable ne convainc pas tout à fait
mais ne convient pas parfaitement mais
nous sommes là et nous l'aiderons à
gagner parce que c'est nécessaire pour
nous tous à vous qui critiquez votre
rallier des républicains
dès que l'occasion se présente en tout
cas vous ne vous ne faites pas de la
langue de bois ça sera lui aussi tout de
même des fois par des actes est ce qu'à
un moment ou un autre vous allez
pourquoi tu as quitté le sillon des
républicains a mais nous nous sommes
plus lentillons des républicains le
parti chrétien démocrate a participé il
ya quatorze ans la fondation de l'ump en
tant que personne morale nous avons été
contents de le faire puisqu'il y avait
là une conjonction des différentes
formations politiques de droite reconnu
chacune dans leur singularité
au moment où nous parlons il n'y a plus
de lien institutionnel montreux le parti
chrétien-démocrate et les répliques
c'est si vous analysez les accords pour
des listes pour l'inscription vous allez
participer on va y sera à la primaire à
droite aussi
nous sommes alliés nous ne sommes pas
mariés c'est toute la différence on va
faire une petite pause avec un micro
trottoir justement avant de parler de la
question d'un présidentielle que savez
vous du parti chrétien-démocrate vos
réponses pas grand chose
c'est pas buts à rien du tout oui mais
je ne les connais pas à quoi tout
simplement je penserai du parti mais
parce que je le connais pas mais je
pense que christina il faudrait qu'il ya
certes un peu et s'ouvre un peu à la
population actuelle parce que je pense
qu'il vit dans un autre monde chrétien
démocrate
je ne connais pas j'en sais beaucoup de
bien j'en ai entendu parler on voudrait
les voir plus on vous allez entendre
plus et voilà je trouve que c'est des
gens qui portent des bonnes valeurs qui
sont devenus presque méconnu puisque
être chrétien aujourd'hui je crois que
personne ne sait ce que ça veut dire
vous faire réagir tout de même parce que
dès qu'on parle en tout cas dans ce
micro trottoir ce qui ressort c'est
parti chrétien démocrate christine
boutin qui était à sa fondatrice et qui
était qui vous à qui vous a précédé pour
la présidence oui oui oui écoutez c'est
d'abord c'est justice parce que et là et
j'ai avec elle fonde effectivement
d'autres partis politiques il ya 14 ans
il en a été donnée qui est
vice-président était vice président est
il en a été la figure de proue et
pendant très longtemps a été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
elle a participé au gouvernement c'est
donc normal que sa notoriété soit soit
conséquente maintenant il a choisi de
transfert de transmettre ses
responsabilités comme un certain nombre
de ses mandats
c'est moi qui en suis maintenant le
responsable il y a deux bonnes nouvelles
dans ce reportage le premier c'est que
nous avons une marge de progression très
sensible dans l'opinion et que
effectivement que nous soyons plus connu
c'est un fait je le concède bien
volontiers je le reconnais je le sais
maintenant sans doute l'élection
primaire qui arrivent nous
donnera-t-elle l'occasion de nous
présenter un peu mieux nous connaissent
qu'à la notoriété hier la grippe a et b
mais bien entendu qu'il ya un déficit de
notoriété je pense que comment dire on
le voit à peu près partout mais je
constate que partout nous sommes
implantés c'est à dire dans tous les
territoires en france ou quasiment
le travail que font nos élus le les
relations qu'ils arrivent à nouer ou à
entretenir avec les élus d'autres
formations politiques vous donne aussi
une assise qui est encore une fois peu
connu mais très efficace très solide le
parti chrétien-démocrate existe même
s'il existe encore de manière discrète
mais le président que je suis est
parfaitement déterminé à faire en sorte
que cette discrétion le prenne fin j'ai
dit vous étiez vous êtes candidat pour
cette primaire à droite ce sera en 2016
pour la présidentielle de 2017
l'objectif on imagine c'est d'obtenir
suffisamment de voix pour peser ensuite
dans l'élaboration du programme commun
derrière votre votre candidat on vous
connaît surtout est parti
chrétien-démocrate aussi pour votre
position contre le mariage pour tous
quels sont les autres propositions que
vous portez et puis peut-être juste
auparavant sur la question du mariage
pour tous vous souhaitez son abrogation
ah oui je n'ai pas changé d'avis sur le
sujet je pense que le à partir du moment
où nous n'abrogerons pas la loi taubira
nous irons vers la légalisation des
mères porteuses ce qui est de mon point
de vue parfaitement inacceptable que ce
serait un recul de civilisation sans
équivalent sans doute qu'on annule les
mariages et en dollar était célébrée non
non c'est pas possible
l'abrogation de la loi ne veut pas dire
que l'on désaffilier ceux qui sont
affiliés au cours des maris ceux qui
sont mariés ça veut dire qu'on arrête de
pouvoir le faire
il y aurait là un signe de symbolique à
mon avis parfaitement important sur le
reste je suis en train de traiter et
nous avons commencé tout à l'heure notre
conversation par ce sujet des je suis
présent sur le plan international nous
avons travaillé dans beaucoup de sujets
comme la défense l'agriculture j'ai moi
même beaucoup plus vrai sur les
questions liées au travail à la
négociation collective aux conditions de
travail et puis également sur le plan
institutionnel je suis à l'assemblée
nationale le vice président de la
commission des lois et à ce titre nous
avons également énormément de choses à
dire ce que nous avons déjà fait mais
avec eux le peu de notoriété qui est qui
est la nôtre sur le champ pénal sur le
champ des prisons sur un certain nombre
d'autres sujets comme cela et sur
l'emploi donc on a énormément de choses
à porter et le projet que je m'apprête à
porter dans
l'enceinte si j'ose dire des élections
primaires sera très complet et visera à
rendre à la france à la fois un peu son
enracinement dans sa culture
judéo-chrétienne d'un côté et veillera à
ce que elle récupère un peu de la
souveraineté qu'il y manque aujourd'hui
est ce que dans le micro trottoir qu'on
a entendu tout à l'heure je vous ai pas
fait réagir sur ça mais il ya un
moniteur un téléspectateur qui évoquait
le fait d'être chrétien parti chrétien
démocrate chrétien aujourd'hui c'est pas
évident il dit c'est pas évident oui et
non je je je pense qu'il ya une forme de
deux d'incompréhension chez beaucoup de
français sur ce sujet être un parti
chrétien-démocrate ça veut dire trouver
son inspiration politique dans le
message qui est la philosophie
chrétienne celle qui a été déployé
depuis 2000 ans dans le monde entier et
premièrement en europe et autour du
bassin méditerranéen
c'est un message qui est centrée sur la
dignité le respect de la personne
humaine sur la liberté sur la nécessité
que les groupes de vie d'humain soit
constitué solide et qu'il soit capable
de rendre des personnes heureuses et
épanouies
ça n'est pas un parc ne sommes pas un
parti religieux même si notre nom
pourrait faire comprendre quelque chose
d'un verse nous sommes un parti qui dit
clairement lui l'histoire les traditions
la culture de la france sont d'origine
judéo chrétienne tant qu'il n'aurait pas
renouer avec cette histoire cette
tradition et cette culture de sortie de
la crise
je crois ne sera pas proche une dernière
question la façon dont se déroule la
primaire actuellement justement parce
que la campagne est déjà engagée même si
elle est régionale auparavant pour pour
l'ensemble des électeurs ya tout de même
cette campagne des primaires qui
s'engagent à droite la façon dont ça se
déroule pour l'instant ça me satisfait
qu'on voit que chacun alors nicolas
sarkozy n'est pas encore candidat mais
en tout cas on voit de plus en plus sur
un plan médiatique et il a fait son
déplacement en russie notamment alain
juppé qui est aussi actif notamment dans
le département des yvelines qui
multiplie les réunions et s'est déplacé
il ya pas très longtemps à moissy la
façon dont ça se passe pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas réussi complètement a
dépassé le stade de la guerre des
écuries ou des chefs
mais sur les personnes jugées puisque
absolument sujet dont je m'écarte
soigneusement je n'ai pas l'intention de
participer à la querelle des candidats
issus des républicains entre eux moi je
suis sur un autre plan qui est davantage
celui du projet pour notre pays et je
m'écarte soigneusement de toutes ces
schémas de rivalité entre les personnes
ils ne sont pas mon sujet ensuite il
reste à régler des questions
d'organisation matérielle très concrètes
sur lesquelles il faut maintenant
commencer à prendre des décisions et je
partage l'avis de ceux de mes
concurrents qui considère qu'il faudrait
maintenant accélérer le mouvement pour
faire en sorte que matériellement cette
élection primaire se passe bien ça n'est
pas rien d'organiser des élections comme
celle là pour tous les électeurs de
france perd tous les électeurs pourront
participer dans dix mille bureaux de
vote ça ne se prépare quoi en claquant
des doigts comme on dit merci jean
frédéric poisson versailles à vous êtes
député des yvelines 10e circonscription
président du parti chrétien démocrate
candidat également donc pour cette
primaire à droite pour la présidentielle
de 2017 le journal se poursuit à présent
comme chaque vendredi avec l'essentiel
de la semaine
si donc le zapping de l'info l'essentiel
de l'actualité que nous avons
développées dans ce journal depuis l on
dit résumé en images une nouvelle
édition de la transat jacques vabre
quarante deux voiliers engagés dans la
compétition depuis dimanche en direction
du brésil parmi les skippers le
versaillais tanguy de lamotte
c'est sa quatrième participation et ce
rendez-vous lui permettra de se préparer
pour le prochain vendée globe
ce sont cinq nouvelles mesures qui
viennent désormais s'ajouter aux 60
annoncé en mars dernier lors du comité
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté
lors de sa conférence de presse aux
mureaux ce matin le premier ministre a
fait savoir la volonté du gouvernement
de reconnaître les obstacles auxquels
sont confrontés les habitants des
quartiers défavorisés les obstacles de
plusieurs natures
je les dis difficulté sociale qui
persiste discrimination parfois ça
s'appelle tout simplement du racisme une
dizaine de sites pilotes vont bientôt
expérimenter une démarche partenariale
avec l'état annoncée le 26 octobre par
le premier ministre la nomination de
délégués du gouvernement qui
travailleront en lien avec le préfet et
le maire je pense des décisions en ce
qui concerne les services extérieurs de
l'état
les mises en place de financements et
puis là la mobilisation s'il veut dire
le du partenariat qu'on a avec eux avec
pôle emploi la caisse d'allocations
familiales avec les différents bailleurs
c'est un projet prévu depuis 2007 qui
s'est accéléré ces dernières semaines
avant la fin du mois de janvier
l'ensemble des services de support à la
recherche quitteront les locaux de
l'inria à rocquencourt pour le site de
paris
l'objectif rassemblé étudiants et
chercheurs sur le même périmètre
nous n'avons pas du tout été associé au
déroulement de
de l'histoire on apprend un petit peu
par hasard que l'inria quitte au
concours pour paris à l'époque c'était
en 2007
de grosses des promesses très importante
avait été fait à part le conseil général
à l'inria pour les maintenir sur place
du coup les enfants vont dessiner sur la
citrouille tout ce qu'ils veulent
enlever et du coup on va plutôt confier
les parents les aux parents les couteau
et l'a ensuite on va découper des signes
et creuser et découpé réaliser sa
lanterne un travail plus physique n'y
paraît mobilisation à présent hier après
midi une cinquantaine d'avocats se sont
rassemblés devant le tribunal de grande
instance de versailles pour protester
contre la réforme de l'aide
juridictionnelle prévus par les
gouvernements
cet appel à la grève a été lancé par le
conseil de l'ordre du barreau de
versailles qui exige le retrait des
mesures actuelles
il demande aux pouvoirs publics de
procéder à une véritable réforme du
financement de l'aide juridictionnelle
la manifestation de lundi répondait et
quelque chose d'un peu spécifique
puisqu'il y a une dizaine de jours il y
a eu des confrères qui se sont fait
molester à lille qui ont été traîné par
terre un bâtonnier a été ceinturé
c'était des avocats qui manifestaient
dans leurs juridictions pacifiquement
ont paisiblement et tout à fait
légalement 90 migrants sont arrivés
vendredi dernier à triel-sur-seine
évacuer ce vendredi matin du lycée
désaffecté jean carré à paris
ils ont été installés dans l'ancienne
maison de retraite des tilleuls
principalement des hommes pour la
plupart originaires du soudan elles sont
encadrées sur place par les
représentants de la croix rouge
française draperies noir tapisserie
façon brocard reconstitution du grand
cénotaphe et jeux de lumière une
scénographie baroque exceptionnelle pour
la nouvelle exposition au château de
versailles
le roi est mort j'ai trouvé ça super
cool
il y avait pas mal d'émotion
je trouve que c'est c'est cool de faire
participer des jeunes pour ça parce que
même si on n'a pas vécu la guerre on
voit on voit tout ce qui est présent
encore comme ça on est on peut être
conscient de ce qui s'est passé avant
voilà donc pour l'essentiel de la
semaine et puis cette semaine également
vous avez découvert sur notre antenne
night farce et le nouveau film de julien
seri il était présent sur yamakasi ou
encore scorpions son nouveau long
métrage met en scène un chauffeur de
taxi et qui n'entend pas laisser partir
ses clients sans payer il a été financé
ce film en grande partie grâce aux
croûtes funding sur internet et il a été
tourné principalement à saint quentin en
yvelines extraits de l'interview du
réalisateur a retrouvé bien évidemment
en intégralité sur notre site internet
grâce au replay c'est un film d'action
mais c'est aussi un peu un film d'auteur
il a été tourné en seulement quelques
semaines à saint quentin en yvelines
oui on a tourné en le premier temps le
capturer trois semaines sur saint
quentin et puis un mois après la fin du
tournage j'ai décidé de repartir en en
shoot et on a retourné une petite
semaine on contourne a dû tourner 24
jours comment on fait pour retourner en
chine si rapidement et bah je crois que
je ne sais toujours pas comment tu as on
n'avait pas le soir donc on avait un
petit budget on n'est pas beaucoup de
temps il fallait évidemment respecter le
planning les délais et puis on a tourné
au mois d'août parce qu'on savait qu'on
allait mettre les enfants en vacances et
donc il fallait qu'on finisse fin août
parce que début septembre c'est la
rentrée des classes c'était facile parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de cinéastes français
qui ne veulent pas tournée en france qui
s'exilent un peu je donnerai mes impôts
vous avez eu des facilités aux tournées
ici à saint quentin en yvelines
on a eu des facilités oui parce que la
ville nous a superbement accueillis
on a vraiment été aidé par par toute la
commune donc on n'a pas eu d'être
financièrement on a eu une aide
logistique et justement qu'est-ce qui
vous a plu pourrait vous avez choisi
justement ce territoire pour tourner
alors on a choisi saint quentin en fait
paul mignot l'un des coproducteurs a
grandi ici et sa maman vit encore ici
chantal mignot est donc un soir paul me
dis mais qu'est ce que tu me racontes du
film
photo rien à saint quentin donc on est
venus en repérage une nuit et j'ai
trouvé la ville assez incroyable
visuellement très très riche avec des
décors déjà mis en lumière ce qui pour
un petit budget comme moi ne pas avoir à
ré éclairer toute la ville grande aide
nightmare à la fiche le 13 janvier
prochain un mot de la programmation de
nos confrères de radio sensations à
présent nicolas kirillovitch reçoit pour
son hebdo politique dimanche à 18h
pervenche berès est député euros
socialiste d'île de france il sera
notamment question de la crise et des
migrants écouter cet extrait une récente
enquête menée par l'institut ipsos dans
sept pays européens indique que 63 % des
français estiment qu'il n'est pas
possible d'accueillir des immigrés
supplémentaires sur le sol français
alors ma question est simple est-ce que
les parties les plus eurosceptiques et
les plus sceptiques à cet accueil dont
le front national en france ont gagné la
bataille idéologique
en tout cas moi je me bats contre le
mauvais vent qu'ils font souffler contre
notre paix dans notre pays jour après
jour
simplement ce que je crois c'est un
mauvais vent majoritaire apparemment
aujourd'hui en tout cas pas pour
l'instant ils sont pas au pouvoir mais
je crois que c'est pire que des
marchands de sommeil il faut c'est ils
n'ont aucune proposition concrète pour
ils ne font que surfer sur la peur ce
n'est pas ne sont pas des vrais
démocrates qui ne s'adresse pas à
l'intelligence des gens la suite de cet
entretien avec pervenche berès
eurodéputés socialistes à retrouver sur
radio sensations dimanche soir retrouvez
aussi sur le compte youtube de la
station quant à nous le journal revient
lundi avec florane parfait sera question
cette semaine de l'opération goodies
l'ined yvelines tourisme nous parlerons
aussi de ce rendez vous autour du
racisme organisée par la commune de
trappes et puis bien sûr est l'essentiel
de l'actualité locale politique sportive
et bien évidemment culturel en attendant
et puisque halloween approche je vous
propose de refermer cette édition du
vendredi avec quelques conseils pour
bien choisir son déguisement le
reportage est signé fanny bourdillon
excellent week end sorcières citrouilles
et bonbons ce week-end difficile d'y
échapper et les magasins compte bien en
profiter pour cette enseigne à montigny
le bretonneux halloween représentent 30%
du chiffre d'affaires annuel
on finit la boutique est vraiment vivre
deux points c'est à ccc c'est une
campagne qui mobilise beaucoup de gens
et c'est les gens pensaient halloween
perdu en france mais en fait c'est pas
du tout le cas pour nous pour des
boutiques comme la nôtre c'est la plus
grosse campagne de l'annexion loupe
halloween on rate notre année avec un
budget moyen de 30 euros les clients de
ce magasin s'arrache cette année les
lentilles de contact qui changent la
couleur des yeux côté déguisements la
série américaine the walking dead a
remis au goût du jour la mode des
zombies et pour les enfants
sorcières et démons reste des grands
classiques j'ai pris un chapeau de
sorcière
c'est donc vos pires et une jupette
vampire est ce pas la mode la grande
vedette vampires est la petite la petite
sorcière donc voila quoi on avait déjà
acheté du rouge à lèvres noir et blanc
et un déguisement de sorcière
je vais mettre le chapeau la sorcière et
veut mettre la robe est ainsi je vais
mettre le nez arrivé en france en 1999 à
louis ii réunit désormais toutes les
tranches d'âge restaurateurs et boîtes
de nuit se mobilisent aussi pour
organiser des soirées à thème